hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to buried now this is going
to be a different type of let's play
because this is an interactive story and
it could be considered a game by many
and I consider it to be a game but also
it involves narration no physical
actions to be taken and a lot of choices
that determine your ending I don't even
know how many endings are in this game
but it's a branching narrative that
covers five chapters and it could be
something really in-depth so let's begin
there's no time to wait around we've got
a lot of choices to make also the thing
about these interactive stories is while
the visuals may be limited in terms of
pictures and text the audio is where
it's really at so I recommend you guys
put on headphones turn up your audio and
get ready for a nice story with
markiplier I opened my eyes and the
first thing I want to do is scream I'm
flat on my back and everything seems to
hurt the trees overhead look familiar
it's a clear night sky almost beautiful
except for the fact that this means I've
been out cold for at least six hours but
there's something wrong I don't remember
what but something happened in my head
my god my head hurts and a ringing in my
ears was there an accident an explosion
I think I remember Dennis screaming but
after that I can't remember as I sit up
I noticed that my hard hat has been
thrown off I look around the area but
it's not here it feels strange to go
anywhere without my hard hat but I've
got to find the other members of the
crew that could be in danger so I say
you might waste time looking for the
hard hat so it's best just to go for the
crew you've already been through an
explosion in you survive so I know I
know this guy's tough I know that I'm
tough I decide that my hat can wait
until I figure out what's going on I get
up and take a look around the logging
site I smell something burning and don't
hear any engines running wait something
isn't right
was it the bulldozer maybe the damn
thing overheated for the last time maybe
the engine finally blew
what a mess well maybe I'm jumping to
conclusions only one way to find out I
guess I walk over to the center of the
logging site and don't like what I see
dead bodies
I'm guessing it's gonna be dead bodies
oh oh that's not good
whoo [ __ ] the logging site looks like a
bomb was detonated right in the center I
don't know where to start the one load
we've managed to stack on a truck for
the day's overturned the trailer Benton
the logs hanging off the back but the
hell is everyone my head is killing me
in this ringing in my ears I can't hear
anything
not Birds not my footsteps nothing it
makes me wonder if I hit my head after
my hard hat flew off I run through a
quick mental checklist to make sure my
brain is still working
my name is Roger Hastings I'm 41 years
old
the year is 2017 I own a small logging
camp and we've been logging in the strip
of Kentucky woodland for almost a month
now okay so my brain works that's a
relief but it also makes me fearful
because something is certainly not right
here I look around the longing cam my
mind trying to figure out what has
happened just about every piece of
equipment has been overturned or tilted
okay so would it be more important to
look at the debris or look at the truck
I mean we can see the truck but I think
looking at the debris would give a clue
to actually what happened here at least
that's my conclusion there are bits of
debris everywhere there are fragments of
the five-gallon bucket a keeper work
rags in a loose sand saw chain and an
overturned gas canister had there been
an explosion all the fuel on site would
have started a fire but there's no
charring no burning nothing I walked
through the area where Dennis had been
working from the looks of it he'd been
moving slowly he had only taken out in
four trees today his metal lunchbox was
open an indicator that he had been
taking an early break but he's not here
no one is here where the hell is
everyone I could try to make a call on
my cell phone but his battery's already
running really low not that it matters
the reception is crap out here so it
looks like calling someone on the cell
phone might actually be a bad idea all
things considered because it seems to me
anyway that that's obviously not gonna
work because a reception is bad and I
might save my phone battery for
something else I'm gonna yell out
I'm gonna yell and see if anybody nearby
hey guys where is everyone
Tony Denis Frank Joe but the names fall
flat among the wreckage I could nothing
back other than scaring away a few birds
overhead might as well start walking try
to find some answers the highway is
almost a mile back through the woods
down the gravel road we used to reach
the site maybe the crew ran that way for
help why would they have left me were
they scared out of sorts maybe I can
catch up to them but with my truck
turned over on his side it looks like
I'll be walking my god I can't even
remember what I was doing before waking
up on my back wait what's that
underneath the bulldozer oh my god it's
a leg it has to be either Tony or Dennis
the dozer looks unstable like it might
roll some more might not be safe to get
close but at the same time I can't just
leave him there well all things
considered they might be dead but you
know what it's worth the risk to go look
I'm thinking hey I yell are you ok are
you alive I skip over the stray logs and
wrecked equipment get closed for seeing
the dozer Titor makes me think maybe I
should have grabbed my hat I can see a
bit more of the leg the jeans are soaked
in blood
I recognize the work boots it's clearly
Tony his leg is bent at an impossible
angle nearly crushed flat the closer I
get the more apparent it becomes that
Tony didn't survive that's not to pull
the body out I mean I get it's his
friend it's its coworker but he's
obviously dead there's no use in trying
to pull his body out to try to get the
dozer will tip over no no need to do
that there's nothing I can do for him
now I start to back away slowly and my
shock I stumbled back suddenly tripping
over one of the stray logs I bang my
hard head hard on one of the logs as I
fall I instantly feel a massive lump
forming on the back of my head damn why
didn't I grab my hard hat but what hurts
more is the realization that Tony is
dead looking at him I feel something
rising up in my throat I don't know if
it's a scream or vomit but I have to
push it away if I lose my cool right now
there are too many questions that will
go unanswered
[ __ ] I can't believe this Tony he had
two boys he coached his oldest son's
baseball team he was the hardest worker
I had one of the most honest and
reliable menin I knew this isn't right I
can't stay here I have to find Dennis
Frank and Joe I have to find out what
happened here so I made a goof and
didn't grab a hard hat but I think maybe
things might have been different if I
did as I walked through the stacks of
logs from the last week or so everything
feels frozen this high-pitched sound in
my ears it's terrible keeps happening
every few seconds like it's coming from
far away I can't help but wonder is it
my ears or is it something else the
silence out here is creepy and there's a
smell like the atmosphere after a bad
summer storm I might as well admit it
I'm a little scared everyone is missing
and it's dead quiet out here that
doesn't even seem to be a breeze to
rustle the leaves and branches my right
knee hurts like hell my head was hurting
so bad before that I never even noticed
the pain in my knee I must have heard it
during them well hearing the what
accident
wait is that Dennis I seem sitting on
the ground motionless about 30 feet away
you know what best stops it best not to
sneak up on him I'm gonna yell I'm gonna
yell in case it's not Dennis hey hi
are you a monster Dennis can you hear me
Dennis lets out a shout like someone
waking from a nightmare he then looks
back at me from the ground yeah Roger I
can hear you he hollers back as I head
over to him Dennis is built like a
wrestler and as the tough personality to
match but in this moment he looks
disoriented and even a little anxious so
I'm glad to see him the fear on his
usually confident face is alarming what
the hell happened
what's going on he asks hey I'm not I'm
not willing to bet that it's an
explosion I'll just say I don't know
don't know the crew is missing Tony's
dead missing where do you think they
went I'm not sure I say but it has be
pretty freaked out something's not right
here
still sitting on the ground he looks
around the woods as if he's just now
understanding the severity of the
situation the equipment was overturned
the dozers - I say waving my forehead
you okay I asked him yeah just shake it
up me too
this might be the most intimate
conversation Dennis and I ever had
well he and I have always been on good
terms we've never been particularly
close I've always respected him though
sure he's come to work a few times
looking like he'd been in a bar fight
the night before but I've also seen him
do an enthusiastic impression of a
dinosaur as he played with Tony's kid
while they waited for their dad to
finish up his shift it's then that it
hits me Dennis and Tony were good
friends I'm not sure I want to rattle
him with the news of Tony's death right
now
not before we know what's going on but
he's the right to know oh yeah you don't
withhold that kind of information from
someone you don't you just don't Tony's
dead you were up front with Dennis about
Tony
Dennis's eyes fixate on me startled he
he was crushed under the dozer I say
Dennis pauses for a moment ladies trying
to understand what I said his eyes
narrow and his bottom lip Quivers [ __ ]
he says and I can tell that he's
fighting back tears he and Tony had been
tithing almost like brothers Hey
he adds quickly as if trying to escape
reality did you see that light no what
did you see I don't even know Roger it
was like this flare of white light it
came right up out of the ground like an
explosion
so there was an explosion I say maybe he
was some equipment er this was no
equipment this huge ball of light came
right out of the damn ground what did it
look like it looked like a ball of light
so might as well ask where it went he
already said would look like where'd it
go it just shot up into the sky
til it was out of sight when I'm not
sure but I finished about 10 trees for
the day and was about to top one that's
when it happened you were almost done
with ten trees I asked ya you know I
wouldn't want to take a lunch break
until I was done and that's when that
light blew up why you don't believe me
no no I believe you Dennis
I believe you 100% you believed in us
his story yeah he saw that what he saw I
think to myself he has no reason to lie
about my god are you okay yeah I'm fine
if I'm being honest it scared me pretty
bad and if it's all the same to you I'd
like to get the hell out of here we've
all stand up and start heading towards
the road it was until we start moving
that I see Dennis's wounded his right
side is coated with blood
the rats seeping through his blue work
shirt their splatters of it here and
there it also very large red splotch
that makes me worry if I ask him if he's
gonna be in a lot of pain the big tough
guy ain't gonna say is I'm just gonna
ask how he got it what happened I'm not
sure I must have gotten thrown or hurt
somewhat from that light it's then that
I noticed the strange ringing noise is
still filling the air hey do you hear
that high-pitched ringing noise every
once in a while
Dennis looks scared when I ask him this
question and he just nods I thought it
was just me he says he looks out of
sorts and uncertain I've never seen him
like this before it's obvious that he's
looking for some reassurance even though
I'm ins boss there's something very
unnerving about this we'll be okay it's
probably nothing there's no reason to
worry the guy so obviously he's shaken
up there's no reason to make him
paranoid about whatever the noise is I
mean it is what it is Woolfolk we'll get
to the bottom of it no matter what but
it is he needs some comfort after the
bad news let's be realistic I tell
myself I might as well try to be
empathetic out here in the middle of
these woods the ringing could be
anything maybe a car alarm from through
the woods or something
still even my passive comment seems to
have reassured Dennis he looks a bit
calmer more relaxed we both start moving
too forward and don't say another word
did you try to call Frank I know he had
his cell on him today
not yet luckily I still have some
battery left I pull out my cell and call
Frank happy I didn't make that call to
Dennis earlier it rings but he doesn't
pick up but when I hear his phone go off
by the stack of logs Dennis and I give
each other a look as the phone goes to
voicemail I hang up and we walk behind
the log to find Frank's phone on the
ground abandoned we look around for
Frank but find nothing not a single
trace it's then that I noticed something
really odd a ten-foot wide hole in the
ground right near where the phone was
but there's no straight piles of removed
dirt or rocks it's clean smoothly dug
cutting into the earth wide but only a
few feet deep it looks so natural like
the ground was just deleted no shovels
or diggers used Danis walks over to it
this looks like the same kind of hole
where I saw that light come from the
ground
I say nothing my mind is spinning but I
don't know what to think we need to get
out of here Dennis mutters at this
moment that ringing noise carries
through the forest again sending his
shiver down my spine Dennis is right
there's something strange going on and
we might not be safe here but that
ringing sound could be a clue to where
the rest of the crew went to be
perfectly honest we can't run away from
the situation we're already in the
middle of it if you're in the middle of
it I guess it would be the first
inclination to go to safety but Frank is
still out there and he could be alive
Tony is dead but we got to find Frank
and the only clue that we got is
checking out the sound you decide to
check out the sound something's not
right and if there's a mechanical noise
like that you think someone is out there
he asks maybe I think we could should at
least check it out they might be able to
help yeah you go right ahead he says
with a grin I'll be waiting for you here
at a hurry though Dennis doesn't look
like he's in the best shape dove dude be
trouncing around the forest but we need
some answers right away - I didn't know
that we'd be splitting up splitting up
is like the worst thing to do but if I
leave him here is he gonna be okay best
to stick together but he is wounded man
this is a bad choice I mean if we were
gonna get out of here then he'd have to
go anyway so dennis has got to come I
can't leave him behind him no you're
coming with me I bend over and hoist him
up on my onto my shoulder he resists
just barely and then gives in he's
looking at me like he's terrified of me
now making a moan in his throat we start
moving through the woods quickly it's no
idea where the rest of the crew is I
worried they could be in danger every
tree out here looks exactly the same
I grew up in the country and could find
my way around the forest without much of
a problem but I'm feeling dizzy I'm
leaning against a tree when I see
something that it's no business being
out here our logging crews been out here
for three weeks and I've never seen it
before
what is it something dastardly in the
darkness its small building sort of like
a mixture of a shack and a bunker it
looks to be made of concrete but moss
weeds and plain old erosion is make it
look sort of mystical it looks like
something out of a demanded version of a
medieval fantasy movie the hell is this
Denis asks I'm not gonna lie I'm not
gonna make her guess I don't know oh and
help no no you purchased this land right
boss didn't you survey it I certainly
did I said getting a little defensive
but this wasn't here do you think the
others maybe went in here he has service
Lee why would they do that I don't know
but they aren't out here
they aren't inside they're probably dead
like Tony he looks at the ground as he
says this I want to go inside not just
to find my crew but also to appease my
curiosity that ringing noise is coming
from inside but something about this
place seems incredibly strange
especially located ball by itself out
here it simply doesn't belong I wonder
do we knock or just go in I can tell
that he's trying to make a joke but it
falls flat I'm starting to think his
humor as a defense mechanism for his
fear we both look ahead take a moment to
realize what we're about to do and start
forward we could no more than three feet
closer when Dennis wobbles reach out to
steady him he's not gonna ask for help
big tough guy like that I reach out
quickly straining my injured knee I
barely make it in time grabbing him
under his arms and keeping him from
hitting the ground I'm okay he said just
can you help me walk for a little while
is help me inside please I can't deny
him his request
I've never seen him this week and it's a
little uncomfortable to see makes me
glad I decided to keep him with me I
help Dennis into the weird little
building the front door opens easily
even though there's clearly a lock on it
maybe the lock was supposed to keep
someone in it's hard to tell I still
hear that ringing noise is definitely
coming from in there stretching out in
front of me is a small interior to match
the outside the building is totally
empty this concrete floor and dingy
featureless walls there are no windows
giving the place an even more isolated
feel still we hear the ringing noise
coming from somewhere in here it's
louder now more prominent the interior
seems confined at first but a small set
of concrete steps leads about five feet
down
revealing a corridor I don't know about
you guys but I'm enthralled with this
and I'm already seeing like how my
choices could have drastically changed
the story and there's a lot of choices
it's a massive corridor in fact like I'm
in some kind of building underground it
seems to go on forever this corridor is
mostly dark with emergency lights over
ten feet or so I assume we're now on the
ground because this corridor extends far
beyond the walls of the building we
entered I realized that someone might
not appreciate finding us here well we
can't exactly walk quickly cuz I mean
Dennis is hurt so might as well go quiet
I feel like a ghost like I truly have no
business here Dennis leans on me for
support
we move slowly our feet not making a
sound if anyone is in Iran to make sure
they don't hear us we tiptoe forward as
softly I was a kid as I carry Dennis to
the far end of this otherwise
featureless place I see a flight of
concrete stairs lending down I have to
set Dennis down on the floor his weight
is killing me Dennis are you okay
stop worrying man I'll be okay I just
need a minute to rest
looking at him I'm not too sure I can
still hear the ringing noise every so
often coming from somewhere in here I
look ahead to the concrete stairs
pointing towards them so that Dennis
sees him can you make it down those
stairs I asked he stands up slowly and
is visibly making an effort to not fall
back down again
yeah he says it sounds a little
irritated he starts for the stairs
without me and I have no choice but to
follow we approach the stairs and by
just looking at them I get the sense
that we're crossing some sort of line
here there may very well be no going
back well might as well keep moving
forward then not much of a choice to be
moved that reminds me of SCP what was it
the stair 108 7b as I head down the
stairs I noticed that they look aged the
damn ringing noises somewhere below
louder than ever I feel like I'm walking
down into the cellar of a haunted house
the light becoming scarce since the
stairs take a slight turn I can feel the
temperature drop Danis makes it just a
few steps down before he's leaning on
the wall he's breathing like he just
finished a marathon I gotta give him a
break he's pushing himself he's probably
losing blood we got to take a break
let's take a break I say putting my hand
towards his shoulder to help
then it's lets out a sigh thanks I don't
feel too great boss as we both squat
down on the stair my mind seems to lock
in on the unknown fate of the rest of my
crew
Frank is married and I met his wife a
few times a nice woman with a huge laugh
my heart sags a bit when I realized I
might never get to hear him belting out
a classic rock tunes during lunch break
Joe well I don't know too much about him
he's 22 years old and is considering
Community College his folks are deadbeat
so he'd been providing for himself since
the age of 16 maybe I can still find him
still could dear Frank singing and his
deep baritone voice after a few too many
drinks after a few moments dennis says
alright let's keep going we both stand
up leaning on each other I have to make
Dennis stay behind me as I stick my foot
out in search of the next step I can't
help feeling like a child is a very
powerful fear seizes me I'm expecting a
monster to reach out darkness slicing
into my throat after what feels like
forever we come to the bottom of the
stairs we're closer to that ringing
noise now a door sits securely in the
wall and looks just outside a place down
here as I feel a sliver of light seeps
through illuminating the area the door
has what looks like a panel with a lot
of labels and lights small embossed
print above the panel says level one
entrance gate transport sector and
there's a button with no label fazbear
best not to be pushing random buttons
let's inspect the panel first the panel
looks like some kind of diagnostic or
alert system was some kind its label
meant to communicate some status
lockdown engaged experiment in progress
shutdown engaged all these appear to be
off but one of the phrases has slowly
blinking red light next to it the only
powered light on this whole thing
abnormal entity breach what the hell I
slowly push the door open there Dennis
suddenly steps in front of me taking the
lead let's go he says I want to find out
what the hell this place is as Dennis
walks through that bringing your beeping
or whatever it was
gets a little louder
the door closes behind us with a click I
can't help but notice the wobble in
Dennis's step as he lets out a grunt you
sure you're healthy enough to keep going
I ask it doesn't matter I don't want to
be in the woods right now he seems
scared something I've never seen before
angry yes upset yes but Dennis is never
scared what did you see what did he see
in those woods I don't know what it was
boss it was like something someone who
left a radio on crackling but we don't
have any radios at the site it was oh no
no it was like something in the forest
was moving I gave him a doubtful looking
he cast his eyes to the ground
frustrated I know how it sounds but I
know what I felt it was like walking
into a funeral parlor feeling death and
gloom everywhere I've never been so
preoccupied with my own fear that I
nearly forgot about the ring noise just
become background noise take a few more
steps and I can now see where we are it
makes no sense yeah another thing that
simply seems out of place the shapes and
muted colors of metal are easy to
identify but it just doesn't belong here
end of chapter one well that is the end
of chapter one and that's fascinating
III didn't expect it to be something
like this but the story is really
interesting respect the dead you and 36%
of players left Tony's body where you
found it you and 76% of players were
upfront about Dennis about Tony's death
you and 55% told Dennis you believed his
story you and 75% of players went to
investigate the ringing sound you and
64% of players decided to bring Dennis
with you that's fascinating
so anyway I'm gonna end this one here
let me know what you guys think of this
cuz this is a different type of game but
I'm already fascinated about what's
going on here
I really kind of want to continue this
and I can make this an easy five part
series it'd just be really interesting
to see what it leads to because if I'm
not mistaken here this almost seems like
an SCP containment breach type thing it
said abnormal entity breach or escape or
whatever that was and it's some weird
facility that's underground with some
strange mechanical containment type
features it may not be exactly
related but you can't help but see some
of the similarities and anything with
SCP containment breach is a fascinating
experience so once again let me know
what you thought of this down in the
comments below I really do want to know
and I really do want to know if you guys
want to see more so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]